so today we're here with three of the
authors of this paper with i have to say
a lot of authors uh it seems like a
giant work just from what i could gather
uh from the from the paper itself and
the data collection and the evaluation
and so on so uh this was a huge thing
but the results are pretty cool so here
with me today are fey shia uh brian
ichter and karl hausmann who are three
of the authors of this work welcome to
the channel everyone thanks thank you
for having us it's great to have you
here uh the i like i love the title uh
because it's a bit of a mantra on the do
as i do as i say not as i do which is
kind of the other way around right here
and this idea of connecting robots and
language it seems pretty natural i have
to say i've i've seen a lot number of
paper attempt to do something like this
like uh can we maybe translate what the
language model says into the space of
what the robot understands and things
like this uh but this here it seems like
a bit of a of a new approach
why
why did you tr why did you attempt to do
this like why does this seem promising
and why did no one else do
this thing yet yeah but i think
to start like the
to i guess like prior work on uh like
using a language model to kind of
translate it down i think we first
started out with sort of like playing
around with that and realized i guess
how much information is imbued in these
language models and how well they're
able to reason over sequences and
remember what they've done
but
when we really like started thinking
about applying it to the world it was
sort of like odd that there's no way to
basically
make sure that whatever it's saying
actually makes sense for the environment
that it was in and so i think like after
playing around that for a while we were
sort of like stuck there like okay we
have these like interesting plans but
they don't actually make sense for
everything that the the robot can do and
so we started kind of like shifting
towards towards that problem yeah i
think also separately we've been trying
to get robots to do many things and
learn multiple skills
and this is a very difficult problem and
we were debating kind of the the best
way to do this whether we should
predefine the skills up front or whether
we should just
demonstrate kind of anything that comes
to mind and label it afterwards
and just connecting these two dots the
the language models with the skills that
we already have on the robots seems like
a a nice way of factorizing this problem
did you always could you so you have
this robot
in this environment and it's if i
understood correctly uh maybe here is a
good demonstration of that they have the
robot in these two environments and
these are the environments that exist to
understand this correctly so it's only
these two environments there's no
generalization across environments
yeah so we've been collecting data in a
few different environments these are the
two environments that we use for
evaluation
we also have a separate environment that
is right next to the environment that is
uh
marked as b here
uh where robots are practicing
but it looks fairly similar to to at
least the stations that the robots
practice on are fairly similar to the
stations that you see here the
backgrounds are changing the the objects
are changing that we practice with and
things like that we also use um
simulation as an additional environment
that we then try to
make look similar to the real world
but we don't really focus in this paper
on generalization to
completely new environment
we rather try to focus on kind of having
a robot do as many things as
in a single environment when we talk
about robot practicing things i guess
that's where your method starts with
robots practicing things and by things i
guess we mean a bunch of very
low level let's call them unit unitary
skills like here for example find a coke
can pick up the coke can bring it to you
something like this so these these could
be things that conceivably we could
learn with something like behavior
cloning or something like this how did
you
decide on what actions are possible for
these robots to do on their own like as
a unit
some of it is based on what the robot's
capable of some of it's like what gives
us a like a easy reward function
and some of it was sort of motivated by
what composes well into long horizon
behaviors that you really want to do in
the world like if we have a robot
operating in a kitchen what would i ask
it to do what what's required of it uh
to do that and how would i break down
the task i think was is like part of the
motivation like really
how this role is going to operate in the
world
yeah and also it's interesting to see
how this picture changes so initially we
kind of have to come up with these and
we kind of have to think up front what
would a person ask a robot to do
but now that we have something running
we can actually ask people and see how
they interact with the robot and
decide on which skills we should be
learning next based on that
all right
so i want to add that um at the
beginning we choose pick and place
because these are
two fundamental skills that can unlock a
large number of instructions that we are
able to solve but it is also very easy
to add new skills into the picture like
we only need to um have a have a
language language description for the
skill and we also need a policy and
value function so these are all the
three three things you need to
import a new skill into the same time
framework
what i like here is that you said you
need a policy and a value function that
policy doesn't even have to be like
neural network based policy conceivably
one skill can be a very classic control
problem i believe when you pick up
things
you
is is that correct that you classically
control where the actuator should go and
when you move the robot you kind of plan
in space
so not everything is like
reinforcement learned or behavior cloned
yeah so different skills are learned
differently in this case pic was learned
through behavioral cloning
on real data
um but yeah for instance for instance
moving around this is not um trained
with reinforcement learning or
behavioral cloning so yeah you can
compose you can have different
algorithms train different skills
and these skills uh just to to round out
the picture right here the input is
whatever the camera sees
plus you know kind of all the states of
the actuators so that conceivably
there's an apple in front of you and the
the task is pick up an apple and that
that would be kind of the state from
from where you operate that's right yeah
we are going and the value function the
value function describes kind of how
likely you are to fulfill that task
that's right yeah so the input to the
policy is the image that the robot sees
that you get at every uh after every
action
um
we actuate the arm by doing end effector
position control
um
yeah
these are the inputs and outputs
and also there's a terminate action
right that's right that so the robot can
say it itself when it's done
yes so one of the actions that the robot
can command is terminate which basically
means i'm done now we can move on to the
next one
and okay so now i guess
this is one part of the puzzle you have
robots you have all these policies for
all the little things that the robots
could do these little things
were developed by you by the community
conceivably you could also use the large
language models itself to suggest new
things to train right on the basic level
you could ask gpd3 what would you do
right here and then the little steps you
could conceivably uh make into like
train into little actions but you have
this library of things and now the
question is how do you how do you
compose them and that's where the large
language models comes in do you want to
comment maybe a little bit on like how
does that look in a base in a basic way
how do we combine the knowledge of
language models with these skills that
the robots can do yeah i guess uh at a
high level so the language model already
has
so much knowledge about the world um
and how to do things in order
and memory and things like that um and
the way to get it to like really speak
in the way that is amenable to the robot
first we showed a few like prompt
examples so we show it solving you know
like about 10 problems um and breaking
it down from the query into the sequence
of steps that it would take to solve
that
it turns out you can actually not use
that and you still actually get like
some level of performance maybe like
half the performance so the language
model just like comes out of the box
with pretty good understanding of these
tasks we then show these examples this
kind of brings it into the right frame
of thought but if you do that and you
ask for something new it doesn't like
fully constrain it in a way that the
robot will be able to understand it so
our tasks along with the image and the
states that we uh mentioned before also
takes in like a task id so it says like
um like pick up the apple so really what
we need it to do is like output pick up
the apple i can't say like pick up the
fruit because
the low-level policies are not
generalizing to that
so to make sure that every time we
actually output things you can do we
instead of like taking the generative
output of a language model we use what's
called a scoring model so when a
language model outputs uh some text it
also comes with a probability that it
would output that text and so instead we
can just like force it to only respond
in these ways and say basically how
likely it is to respond in that way so
in this case we get like a score of if i
were going to pick up the apple or put
the apple somewhere these are the things
i'd like to respond these are the things
there's no way i would respond and this
gives us some like probability that the
language model thinks this is really
useful to the downstream task on the
other side we have these value functions
and policies that we've talked about
they're actually the value functions
outputting how likely it is to achieve a
task i think actually there's another
slide one like one more down
um but this is basically oh yeah this
yeah is saying basically these are
possible from this state and so on one
hand we have a language model saying
this seems really useful for the task
and the va on the other hand we have the
value function saying
this seems possible and together they
give some probability that this is what
you want to do to basically accomplish
the high level instruction
i have a number of
okay let's just start at at the
beginning at the at the language model
level i see the high level picture you
you ask both the language model and the
value functions what's what you know
what they think should happen next and
uh the combination of the two is what
then you really do which makes a lot of
sense when you do ask these language
models what to do
um
right here you said you use the
you use the
essentially you ask the language model
for the likelihood of an output instead
of letting it generate the output uh was
this your first try because one could
also imagine uh you know saying
something like of the following options
which one would you pick right and then
you list all the options which would
conceivably
be more general because you could opt
you could add options over time and
stuff like i guess you could do that
here as well but um
was this your first attempt or did you
did you have some prompt engineering
attempts before that
yeah i think at first we tried just like
prompt engineering to see like basically
what the generative model would output i
think like our our initial thinking was
we just want the generative model to
basically plan as much as we can
but that runs into two problems one is
that it doesn't constrain the output
fully so if i give it all these examples
and then i said
how would you put a fruit on the table
instead of an apple on the table the
generative model will actually respond
with like number one find a fruit number
two pick up the fruit um and then you
need to figure out how to like take that
and project it into the final
like thing that the robot can actually
handle um you can project this in some
sort of like embedding space and that
works sort of well but you actually lose
some context on the overall query so i
guess the way that we do it is a little
bit more like um
well founded uh so to speak
uh but the other really nice benefit of
this is it gives us scores for
everything which is really interpretable
it lets us like see the trade-off
between these two options so in your
example you said you know what if i just
said here are your options pick one and
the language model would probably pick
one but now you only know that this is
its favorite option you don't know the
probability that it would have done
maybe maybe it's actually okay with the
next three options so this gives us this
like interpretable
um score that we can then combine with
the value functions
yeah
i mean
there are some caveats to this i feel in
that for example we know that by
definition longer outputs are less
likely right so
i guess it's not too much of a problem
for you because most of yours are like
three or four words but have you noticed
any of of kind of these effects of just
you know how these probabilities are
constructed as kind of multiplications
of soft outputs like that's got to bring
its own bias into the into the picture
have you
observed any of that have you had
problems with any of that or was it was
it generally okay
yeah it's it's definitely uh a little
bit of an issue i mean i think in
general it's also very uh particular to
the
to these like if you were to misspell a
word in there or like have an a versus
an an it's not particularly robust to
those in the options it is in the query
like to what the user might say but not
when you're scoring these options
because if one word is off then this
like multiplication of each word just
kind of tanks the entire score
um so we did have to be somewhat careful
with what we have
one way to kind of like get around this
a little bit is if you have some like
end of statement token and if it uh
if it
adds extra words on the end then it's
saying if there's like more to come that
end of token will basically kind of
normalize the rest of it like you can't
end a statement early
um
the
yeah i think in the other thing that we
did try to do is like potentially
normalize them so
knowing that this query is longer
perhaps we
need to upgrade it or have some
normalization on the language output but
we found that it wasn't particularly
consistent
and there wasn't like
just a constant effect across one or the
other and it depends on the way you like
referred to the query and so at the end
of the day
we just took the outputs as they were so
it was an issue but it wasn't like a
huge one
um
i imagine that
there's another factor here for example
if you if you say
you said before pick up a fruit or
please bring me a fruit or something
like this you're essentially relying on
the ability of the large language model
to sort of recognize that apple is a
fruit and and and kind of interpret that
in the same way and and so on so the the
kind of clo as the language model
estimates how close the things are did
you find this generally an agreement of
in how how humans find how close the
things are and
um maybe yeah i'm just i'm just
wondering about this notion of how how
close things in language are together
also what happens if you for example
have an apple and an orange in your
scene these two things would be quite
close together so even if you said you
know please pick up an apple the pick up
an orange thing would conceivably score
quite high in the language model which
might perturb your things so i i can
kind of
i can sort of make out that you have an
ideal environment right here
in that you probably picked objects that
are distinct from each other locations
that are fairly distinct from each other
right such that there's a nice semantic
gap between the things
what like
do you think this is well applicable to
a real world setting or what kind of
hurdles could there be with connecting
language models and and a set of actions
in this way
so i guess the first question was about
um
do these families kind of align with
what you would expect and that was
actually that was one of the first
things that i was looking at was like
how well do these scores sort of
match up to what you
think it's going to be so yeah it turns
out that like apple and
orange and banana are all going to score
quite highly when you're asking for
fruit if you ask for a snack all the
food options are going to score highly
similarly drink
soda any category like that and it
performs about yeah as you would expect
as a human
which is good but then yeah it comes to
this problem of
what if there's an apple in orange or
what if there is an orange but not an
apple and that's where these value
functions come in this is actually like
one of the key reasons why we have to do
this embodiment grounding because if you
just asked a regular language model that
doesn't know what's there then how does
it make that decision maybe it chooses
the wrong one then your plan isn't
really correct um and our policies may
not actually work
um but the value function tells you
if there is an apple in the scene and no
orange then you're going to see a high
value function on the apple because the
pick apple command could work versus the
orange command is going to be quite low
and so that actually lets you sort of
like disambiguate this so
in the in figure b if it had uh pick up
the red bull if you said bring me a
drink and there's a red bull but no
water it's going to pick up the red bull
because that's actually what's there
and if not then then the instruction
itself is ambiguous right if you say
pick up a drink and there's two drinks
and both are affordable according to the
value function yeah yeah then we think
like either is completely fine i think
it's also interesting because um then
the robot is making the trade-off um
itself depending maybe on the value
function so for instance if you ask for
a fruit and there's an orange and an
apple but it's much better at picking up
apples
maybe it will pick up the apple because
the value function will just tip the
scale
so it will make some errors in that
sense but since this is interpretable
and you can kind of look back and see
why it decided for that it can also
inform us as to what skill we should
train a little bit more or which value
functions are a little underfitted
and things like that so it it will make
some sort of mistake
but maybe that's
that's okay like maybe that's acceptable
i think one like really nice feature of
that too is it's not necessarily always
like it's better at picking up oranges
or apples but you can see like these uh
objects are in different locations one
may be better for the policy than the
other
so we're going to end up doing the one
that's a little more robust and a little
more likely to succeed as long as it
still fulfills the high level query
yeah i like the fact that you have
success probability as sort of the the
ultimate score because i was i also
thought one failure mode here is that
some tasks are inherently harder than
others right and so naturally your value
function would be lower and therefore
you can misinterpret just by the fact
like uh well like th this this this is
me the procrastinator like um this thing
seems really hard i'm gonna do this
other thing that it doesn't really help
but it's really easy right
so
it's almost it's almost too human how
the robot would act in this way
so yeah you have these
what i like here as well is that
you have the bank of value functions on
one hand the language model on the other
hand and they are never if i understand
correctly trained together right
there they're never in fact the language
model is probably just frozen
um
so they're never trained together which
means that you could conceivably just
add a skill to the robot train its value
function for it and just plug it in and
and go
yeah
we can scale this fairly easily so we
can continue adding skills we can also
change the underlying algorithm on how
we train the skills or how we train the
particular skill that we want to add if
we if suddenly there is a really good
script that allows to
i don't know
swipe the floor or something like that
we can we can also add that as long as
as we have a value function for it
and also at the same time if the
language model becomes better we can
also swap out the language model and get
improvements through that
i want to add that so currently value
function is one way that we instantiate
affordance but uh there are many other
ways that we can instantiate affordance
like for example we can directly do
prediction uh we can also use classical
motion planning like to calculate for
example length of the trajectory is also
or the the probability of success if you
do like sampling based motion planning
so there are many ways that we can come
to the affordance and the method is
really flexible to plugging any type of
affordance
i guess a a big topic in
uh maybe maybe it's more of the space of
blockchains and things like this is
agents that do an action for you but
also optimize for example for cost or
for resources or something like this
this could directly flow into that where
you can tell the robot you know do
whatever
fulfills my task but also costs very
little and this could if this directly
flows into affordance uh there might be
a normalization issue but if this
directly flows in uh you you'd have you
could
tune the knobs on these on these
functions fairly easily so this is the
full algorithm i guess we haven't talked
yet about how you extend this to
multiple steps but it is as far as i can
tell fairly easy in that you do this in
sort of a a stepwise fashion so first
you ask your language model your value
functions uh at the current state and
the current camera position where
what should be done
then you try to whatever should be done
according to both scores combined you
execute that
and after you execute it you ask the
same thing again but now the prompt
changes and it's simply that you so here
the prompt is essentially i would first
and then first action is decided and
once you go on
the prompt now says
i would first and then whatever was
decided on and then second and then it's
simply the same thing with the next
action
did i get this approximately correct
do you pay any attention to whether or
not the task was fulfilled successfully
so right now we don't we assume it will
successfully execute i think
some things could happen like if it
fails at a navigation task say it was
trying to navigate to an apple and the
um
and it doesn't get there then the value
functions at that next state are going
to be quite low so you're not going to
be able to basically pick something up
or whatever so maybe then you end up
selecting navigate to the apple again or
navigate to a table instead but we don't
have any like explicit success detection
i think this is like one area that we're
like pretty interested in going
basically like finishing the job closing
the loop entirely
on when you try to do something did you
succeed telling the language model and
then having the language model adapt
accordingly
i want to show one video from from your
website which in this case if i got this
right it confused me
i guess a little bit because this thing
right here if you see it kind of looks
around sees all the things
right it like looks and sees and then it
kind of
scores the actions
and like this
so pick apple i can't do that pick
sponge okay
um bring you a sponge
no not go to trash can place the sponge
place the sponge is good and that's the
place the sponge kind of up ways to
bring you a sponge
or
like what's going on right here because
in in my in my estimation the robot
shouldn't even look around initially the
robot should just have its camera
position uh fixed and then
it in first instance it should probably
figure out like find a sponge or
something like this and then it would
move and then it would see consider
these next actions like uh what is what
is this video supposed to to show yeah i
think your understanding is completely
correct so this is more like a
conceptual video where we wanted to kind
of trust that it can accomplish longer
tasks but you're right that the way it
would happen is that it would look at
the current image then it would decide
that it first needs to find a sponge or
maybe pick up the sponge if the sponge
is already available then append that to
to prompt and continue
so we just wanted to make it short so
that you can still get get that idea
across but only by
having a single image
uh yeah so it might be a little bit
confusing that doesn't i think uh depict
fully how the method works
yeah i think we just got excited by the
visual of a language model sort of uh
seeing nothing and then waking up and
seeing oh i'm a robot uh okay here's my
history of what i've done before okay
depending on that what i thought i made
a lot of sense doesn't make any sense
anymore so it's more like excitement
than anything else
it does look pretty sweet like
it looks pretty cool
especially like the the effects on like
the zoom
uh
seeing what's around
um you you use by the way we've we've
not shown this yet you use these um
you use these everyday robots uh
constructions which look
oh it looks semi-creepy but also quite
cool
especially when they pick up stuff they
like hold it behind their back like it's
like a mixture of a butler and someone
who just has a knife and wants to stab
you
but pretty sweet and it works
surprisingly well um
so
maybe we can talk about the results of a
little bit
uh next because my next question would
sort of be okay how well does it
actually work
in the environments where you test it on
do you maybe want to
comment a little bit on what was the
what were the general results and then
you have some ablations
yeah do you want to take this or do you
yeah i think i can take this so we test
this on uh two environments uh one is
the real office kitchen um and another
one is a kind of a mock office kitchen
uh showing in figure 5 i think and we
tested on 101 instructions
from like six categories
um yeah so here here are the test
environment the a is a real kitchen and
b is a mock kitchen
there are 15 objects that we focus on
and also five semantic semantic
locations like these locations are
semantically meaningful like table trash
can close counter file counter
and a robot operator location where we
define like bring back to you that's
where it is supposed to bring it back to
we test on 101 instructions from six or
seven categories if you scroll down a
little bit uh it's mainly to test
different capabilities of the robot for
example can it understand synonyms like
non-synonyms uh or verb synonyms like
what does throw away mean uh throw away
means bring something to the trash can
like recycle means bring something to
the trash can and also structure
language uh which is just like verb
non-uh compositions um and also we test
embodiment which means we test if the
robot understand uh what this current
embodiment is for example if i already
pick up something i shouldn't try to
find it again because i already have it
also we test on crowdsourced uh
basically uh it's unstructured human
queries from like co-workers for example
and long horizon tasks which are some of
the real really challenging instructions
such as i spilled my coke on the table
how would you throw it away and then
bring me something to clean so that's a
really challenging task the robot need
to understand what does spell mean like
what tools you can use to clean up a
spill so these are the instructions that
we tested and overall i think we
achieved
71 percent planning success rate and 66
execution success rate
um and um uh it the the hardest question
is do the longer horizon tasks so i
think we only have about like 30 or 40
percent success rate
um
and yeah we are working on uh improving
those um like other
success rate on those harder questions
right if you have anything to add yeah
the only thing i was going to say is
that uh
the long horizon ones are particularly
challenging both from like reasoning and
language side but a lot of the issue
comes with if you have like a 90
success rate manipulation policy which
is still quite high uh every time you do
this you reduce the probability that
your overall plan is going to succeed
and so that starts to
like
both it's a big challenge and we want to
get our manipulation policies better and
better and each of our low-level skills
better and better but also having some
sort of like closed loop that so the
language model knows to retry would be
really helpful here
and
you uh i saw i saw in the results that
it was it's pretty interesting in that
you did ablate a lot of these things for
example you did ablate what for example
if we don't have the language model and
these okay these are the overall success
rate you play what if we don't have the
language model and what if we don't have
the the scoring model and generally they
were worse much worse in both cases
which was pretty cool to see and not
always the same except in this one
it is one thing do you understand this
correctly if you
drop the generative model
oh no generative uses ah it uses a large
language runner projects the nearest to
the nearest skill via an embedding
that is actually better than your
original policy is that just noise or is
there something behind it if you use
this verbs category
my guess is i think it's more noise than
uh
than anything else
but there were definitely times where so
i mean we see it like really fail in
certain circumstances so embodiment
because there's no value function there
to tell it that it can't do something um
there's a real issue for it and so there
were a lot of failures for anything that
didn't have a value function there
i do think we saw some like
some pretty interesting differences
between the uh no value functions so
this is the scoring model only without a
value function
and the generative model
and so some of the issues with the
generative model came around with like
nouns for instance and this is because
when you do this projection so the say i
said i just worked out i won a snack
it then projects to or then uh these the
plan will say bring me a snack but
really what i want is a snack to help me
recover from my workout and so that like
a little bit of information is enough to
say it's probably not like potato chips
but maybe something like healthier
similarly like a drink there would lose
a lot of its information and so on the
noun ones we saw that it ended up like
losing this information and that cost a
lot of the success rate uh whereas the
scoring model did okay across the board
but maybe not as like smoothly in the
the verb category
another really fascinating thing here is
at least in my opinion just the scale of
data collection in this project um i
have i have made a few notes and at one
point it says something like
uh you use a lot of human labelers for
for example the success rate of these
little policies so even when you train
these little uh or small
unit let's call them unit policies
um you use humans to see whether they're
correct or not and you use three human
raiders per execution and you get it you
get give a
one single sparse reward
if two out of three agree
so
like this scale seems immense right is
is really
like how did you determine this was the
best way to
spend the human time and not maybe to
gather uh more noisy but three times
more labels or something like this like
how did this come to be
yeah this is a good question i think we
are still figuring this out a lot of
these questions and how to spend um
how to spend human time in the most
efficient way that that helps the
policies the most
and i think there is a question of
crowd labeling as you as you mentioned
so how much noise can you tolerate in
the reward function
uh
compared to like the throughput of that
um also
how much time you should spend
collecting human demonstrations versus
how much time your humans maybe should
be just supervising robots collecting
data autonomously how much should we be
spending time developing assets and
policies in simulation and transferring
them to the real world so we are still
kind of trying to
find the trade-offs between all of these
i don't think we have any any very good
answers right now uh as for labeling
itself
um
we notice in previous projects that the
the noise and the on the reward signal
is
can be really
i can have a big influence on
performance so that's why we decided to
have three labeler labelers to uh to
agree on the the two of which we have to
agree to to market a reward and we also
had additional questions such as was the
behavior undesirable or unsafe and these
are sometimes quite ambiguous
so it's actually it helps quite a lot to
have multiple people look at the video
and and tell us what they think
did you always have these additional
things in uh so you have as you say and
also i wrote this down somewhere a
unsafe undesirable or infeasible um did
you always have this in or was this kind
of a development that happened over time
that you realized oh crap we're asking
people how likely is the robot to pick
up an apple but there's no apple in
sight and things like this
yeah so some of them we added so
initially we knew that safety is a is a
big problem so we started with with that
question then we noticed that sometimes
the robot would do something that isn't
necessarily unsafe but we still don't
want it to do it for instance it will
touch the object that it wasn't supposed
to touch or it will just poke something
and it will
fall off the table so then then we added
the the undesirable which is like has a
slightly different definition
and we can also optimize for it
differently in the reward function
and then
[Music]
regarding the
uh the last one the infeasibility this
is something that we notice with
reinforcement learning algorithms that
if you
add a lot of data where the task wasn't
feasible even though the data is
technically correct right the robot
didn't accomplish the task it got reward
zero
but it seems to be
influencing the rel algorithms in a bad
way so we added this
in addition to prevent that and
potentially filter for this data or see
how we can change the url algorithms to
handle that kind of data better
and why do you only give a single reward
i mean presumably a human watching a
video like this could be you know every
couple of frames could be like yeah good
job robot yeah that's the right way yeah
oh no don't do that like essentially
like peter pan or like you know warmer
warmer warmer colder colder which would
give sort of a much more dense label
space uh was is this like a technical
limitation or did you also consciously
choose to say no we got
it's one single reward
and that's only it's one when you
fulfill the task and zero everywhere
else yeah so there's i think a few
reasons for this first i think the
ambiguity that comes with it um you know
it's already sometimes difficult to
decide whether the task was accomplished
correctly or whether it was undesirable
or not if in addition to this you have
to add this continuous signal whether
the robot is going in the right
direction i think
it can be fairly ambiguous depending on
what the robot is doing
secondly um we made a decision um some
time ago
um that
um optimizing for sparse reward tasks
would be just uh more scalable for the
future that's there are some tasks where
it's quite difficult to say whether the
robot is actually
going in the in the right direction and
sometimes it accomplishes a task in a
surprising way and we don't necessarily
want to kind of eliminate that and
introduce human bias of like well i
think it should go that way um
so our url algorithms that we've been
developing have have also been optimized
for the sparse reward setting
so that was kind of another factor that
we
that we thought about when
uh when considering the reward function
so speaking about uh doing it like
humans there's a yet another set of data
collection in this project and that is
that not only do you collect the labels
but you also do quite a considerable
amount of behavior cloning from
essentially learning from demonstrations
from humans with another set
of data gathered from uh you call it
tele-operated tele-operator sessions how
how can we how can we imagine such a
teleoperator session like how many of
these kitchens and robots do you have
and how how long does this take to
gather a data set that you could
conceivably do behavior cloning from
yeah so
i think we specified in the paper that
we gathered at that point around 70 000
demonstrations for all these different
tasks this is across 11 robots i believe
we built a little we built little
stations for the robots like the
stations that you can see in the picture
here where the roads can can practice
these things and people can demonstrate
how to
how to how to do things i think um
we are still kind of trying to see
how much of this if we if we filter the
data set for instance how much can we
filter it and still get really high
result so i think we we don't have very
good answers to that yet
um yeah but this is something we're
looking into kind of the trade-offs
between how much demonstration how many
demonstrations you're collecting how
much autonomous data and so on
where is
this just because this is at google
which is a company and sure there's like
a cash cow that
generates infinite money but there's got
to be
some kind of constraint on you
just
or how do you how do you how does this
work maybe
what robotics at google uh what is your
mission there and how do you pitch such
a thing to to management like yeah
essentially we want to collect 70 000
sessions of tele-operated things every
time a human presumably not a random
human because they would just crash the
robot
out of spite uh but like a trained
trusted human needs to sit down and
spend their time and their robots are
quite slow as of now like
this there's got to be a considerable
budget behind all of this data
collection and labeling and so on uh how
do you do you have to make a case for
that or are you relatively free in doing
this how does
how does your work in the that's saying
in the business perspective look like
um yeah i think in any company you kind
of have to make a case or even in in
academia you have to make a case for
your project why you think this is
how the money should be spent and where
the resources should go
um so usually the way we we kind of
justify it is by showing
um kind of step-by-step results and
showing if we extrapolate this where
this is going to go so we we
we've done some projects previously
where we showed reinforcement learning
at scale with six robots or uh behavior
cloning at scale with just two or three
robots and then we start seeing that
with the amount of data that we
collected there we already can see some
interesting results and now if we want
to get these robots to do
many more things
uh we need more robots we need more data
and this is kind of one
big bet that we that we have in robotics
at google is that
this large-scale machine learning
could be a way to to really help
robotics
um so
we want to we want to be able to de-risk
some of those questions for the for the
community right like if we can actually
buy a lot of robots and provide a lot of
demonstrations how does it scale
uh how does it work
i think one of the slides or one of the
figures in the appendix actually has
somewhat like the way that we built up
these skills uh one by one it's maybe i
don't know what page it's on but it's a
little higher than that
yeah this one
sort of shows like how these were built
up over time and and how more one more
and more skills were added more and more
data was collected each time seeing
signs of life for the algorithms and
performance and improving upon that
and you can see that from time to time
there's a new skill being added so that
kind of goes from zero up in the
meantime the results of the underlying
code is changing
so it's kind of like improvements over
time
so this goes it goes up and to the right
which is what we all love and uh was
there was there major downturns in this
project like times where
you know things didn't seem to work out
or you didn't exactly know
what the problem was things like this
could you get us a bit behind the scenes
into when when things go wrong
hmm
no problems
there's quite a lot i'm just trying to
think which one to tell you about
uh there's quite a lot also from
previous projects but um
i think one thing that
was quite surprising to to me personally
and i think we are still kind of working
on that is that
um
if you spend in if you uh classify
approaches into let's say
uh imitation learning and reinforcement
learning approaches if you spend enough
time
and data on either of them you can get
them to work
so we some of the the results that you
see here most of them are from
behavioral calling but we can achieve
very
um
comparable results with reinforcement
learning either by transferring policies
from simulation and then
continue
collecting with that policy and kind of
fine-tuning it to a high performance
or by just bootstrapping from real data
and improving upon that
but
what is quite surprising is that
combining these these two have has been
quite tricky
so kind of having a single algorithm
that can digest all of that data that
can digest all of the demonstrations as
well as the autonomous data that was
collected data that we collect in
simulation and so on and have it have
all the properties that we want so it
performs at least as good as behavioral
cloning but it can also improve
autonomously and so on this has been
this has been quite surprising and
tricky
um
i want to maybe
have a bit of an or make a bit of an
outlook right here because it seems we
have a pretty cool
way to go from
skills that are described by language
but you have to define them
let's just scroll to one of them you
have to define them ahead of time right
you have to define pick up the coke can
bring it to you find the coke can and so
on you have to just you have to design
these uh even though they're described
by language they're a pretty fixed set
now the first thing that maybe one can
think about is how to extend that set
and
not necessarily extend it just linearly
but i'm thinking of something when i say
please clean up the table
you might not know what's on the table
so we need this kind of a concept of
like almost like a variable or an
unknown
you know like
so the plan could be go to the table and
then kind of
decide what to do next so the language
model
could get even or has to get a feedback
almost from either
the
the value functions or from the picture
itself right is that anything that's on
your your radar um sort of what if i
don't what if i have to adjust my plan
on the fly to the state that i'm going
to encounter how
could this model be extended to
to handle that
let's say all the actions are in your
action space right but you just don't
know at the beginning which ones you're
going to take
yeah i guess right now we kind of like
count on the value functions to sort of
like collapse whatever your plan is into
the the
thing that is actually possible in the
world i think like one of the
most i guess
straightforward
ways to do it though maybe not
straightforward in practice
is to
use things like visual transformers
or
like structured scene representations
that actually tell the language model
what's possible so that they can start
like reasoning over it earlier on
um the other thing is to add in
something like these success rates
success detectors that say okay you
tried to do this and it wasn't possible
so maybe you tried to find an apple that
was impossible perhaps the next thing to
do is try to find an orange that may
actually be in the scene so there's some
like combination of value functions
giving it
feedback about the scene
but right now we don't have anything
that like has the language model really
really reasoning over the steps because
the value functions takes take care of
that like interaction
but one could fine-tune it on some data
that allows it to to do that is probably
the
most straightforward way to do it but
whether that works is
open question
i guess the the other thing is and this
would really also close the loop or
close one of the loops is if i imagine
that i also had a model that could take
any visual input and then kind of
describe that
uh describe what's happening in the
visual input so i'm going to give it a
video of pick up the of something
picking up the coke can and the thing
would come up with like a label for it
like oh this video shows pick up a coke
can right
then i'd have
almost limitless possibilities i could
just let a robot
move at random essentially let the
language model or let this model
describe what it's doing
then kind of feed that to the language
model and so on so instead of you
designing
the actions that it should train i could
just let it do stuff and then have a
model describe that stuff and then use
that is is that a plan or is there like
a major hurdle on the way there because
that will kind of result in a almost
autonomously learning system if you give
it a good language model the language
model could even also prompt it what to
try next right like the language model
could be like okay what should i learn
next i should probably learn to pick up
an orange and then you just
ran them around until the thing the
description model says ah this looks
like picking up an orange
i guess i can say something first and
then i will ask like carol because he
has previously worked karen and brian
worked a little bit on like learning
from play data so would you describe
kind of similar to that what i want to
mention is that we find language is a
great
kind of state obstruction because people
invent language because they abstract
some state right like every every every
word every sentence is meaningful so
there's some work in language
showing that accusing language
obstruction can improve exploration for
example you can use that to guide your
exploration and
summarize current states so that's uh
one potential direction that we can go
yeah i think there's kind of multiple
ways you can see
pushing this uh to an extreme
i think like one small step in the
direction would be rather than having
these predefined skills label everything
in hindsight as i think you're
describing as well
and um
and train policies based on the
hindsight labels so it's not just pick
up an apple but you know no matter kind
of however the person that looked at
that video described it that's the skill
that the robot was performing
and then you maybe don't have to
constrain the language model to pick
across the skills that you train but
maybe you can just take the generative
output and see how that works
i think there is also
um a potential um
potential research to be done in um how
much can language actually take from the
robotics problem and how much can it
help solving it so right now we are
operating at a certain level of
abstraction like you command things like
pick up the cocaine
and then the language model can operate
on that but you can also imagine
operating on much lower level which is
just like you know move this direction
or that direction or something like that
and the language model commands all of
that and you kind of you can choose
where in that abstraction you want to be
and i think it's it's quite interesting
that
we we at least can contrive things like
this because of how good language modes
are today yeah and i think i guess to
that there's also works on using
language basically to predict rewards um
like over states and so that's like one
way to kind of like hook it all together
we have this like general framework
what's the
biggest hurdle like what's the biggest
let's say unsolved problem to push
push these sort of everyday robots not
the company but like the the uh the
expression the robots that help us doing
our tasks
where's the like the biggest roadblock
in getting these to a point where they
could actually be usable
um i think right now given kind of how
much time we spend on different parts of
the system it's the skills themselves
the the ball neck is still the robot
actually doing the thing that you ask it
to do
even though these skills are simple to
get them to to the place where they
generalize to any environment can kind
of pick up any object even the object
that it wasn't trained on
and do these tasks in you know
with large diversity of objects
environments and so on to very high
performance this is still really really
hard
so i think if
if we get much better skills underlying
skills
then
um
well would have made a big step towards
this actually being
very useful
and i was gonna say the along with those
skills like the way that we use
the value functions is that as the skill
improves so does the like value
function's estimate of what it can do
so it's kind of nice we're like position
both to use these skills but it also
improve the overall algorithm by having
a better estimate of a success
probability so i think we're like i
think seikan itself is at least set up
in a good way to sort of like scale
along with as this bottleneck is
relieved
last question from from my side what do
you think of the tesla bot uh and when i
give you the the short pro in in
in briefly in that it is the ultimate
platform because the world is designed
for design for humans right so if you
have the humanoid robot conceivably it
could do anything the human can at least
mechanically
do you
does this sound
good to you or is there like major
skepticism
no comment
[Music]
you can you can wager wait your bets
right now i think one one thing that is
maybe
that i'm excited to see is um
i think uh
um tesla has the ability to scale things
up quite well
they're they
they seem to be a really good hardware
company
and uh so it would be interesting to see
how some of the problems change this is
also things that we are researching as
well how problems change and how
solutions change when you have many many
of these robots
um
so i would be
i would be excited to see if they have
any any good insights there
is there uh last things that we maybe
haven't touched on yet that you would
like people to know
um here just for visuals i'm showing
some of the successful episodes at the
end which are quite impressive like very
multi so there's just one robot just
this is this is a collage but very
multi-step things and i think that's
just a really impressive uh very long
horizon planning things
down to these individual actions
um yeah that's that's pretty cool
anything any last thing you want to
want to let people know how can they get
started uh where can they find out more
information i just want to mention that
we have the website on the website we
have a couple videos demo demonstrating
how the robot like works and how the
inference process works along with the
decision process all the scores that we
have calculated along with the robot
execution so if there are anyone
interested in um
like how our algorithm works check
definitely check that out
i think like i guess what i'm most
excited about with it is like
how interpretable it is that you can
actually see how the decision is being
reached by the robot that you can see
that the language model likes these
things and that the affordance model
understands that these tasks uh
make sense or do not make sense in a
given world uh embodied environment
um i think it's like nice that it scales
really well um to adding in new tasks as
we go
um
and then i guess towards how people
would use it i think to start yeah i
mean the paper and the website's a good
place to to go i think we're planning to
open source a version of it on a more
kind of toy environment in the the
coming months so hopefully that'll be
like an exciting like easy way to sort
of like get in the mix with both this
and language models i think there's a
lot of power in in leveraging language
models and kind of giving them these
like hands and eyes to execute real
world tasks
um i also think you had a a point
earlier about basically like we use
affordances but
really it's just a value function it's
this value function doesn't necessarily
have to map to an affordance and i think
that's a really powerful idea that we're
basically taking all the knowledge in a
language model and then hopefully
applying it with a value function that
isn't even necessarily normalized to can
you do this or not it's sort of what's
helpful what's possible for whatever the
rl trained policy is doing i think
that's like a really i don't know open
space
yeah i'm cool i'm also quite excited
about how uh
language can kind of chip away a little
bit from the robotics problem
uh i think that's something that we
haven't really thought about that much
before and we see that we can handle you
know much more much longer horizon
commands abstract commands and so on
while keeping the policies fairly simple
so uh it's i think it's quite exciting
to see how much further we can we can
push that direction yeah i think
representations have always been such a
challenge for especially like past
representations they're such a challenge
for robotics
and i think language has provided this
like really nice interface to interact
with uh the robot and then have the
robot interact with the world
excellent
well uh carl brian faye thank you very
much for being here this was a lot of
fun and i hope to see you again soon
yeah thank you thank you for having us
[Music]